maybe would have meant to be I think a
lot of people are wondering just because
of what's happening with Netflix could
this be the end of the Punisher do you
think that if it is are you happy with
the way that the show ended or do you
think we're we're getting more I mean we
you know the truth is we don't know we
see we see you know so you know I've
been buddies with Charlie Cox for a long
time i binge the third season devil Thor
was terrific so it's obviously got
nothing to do with you know qualities of
shows I don't know what it does have to
do with but but I think that we made
this show not knowing about any of this
stuff and we wanted to make a really
satisfying interesting fresh show that
was not season 1 but you know no no no
concept that is the end of anything so
and the truth is also when you're
filming you're so busy we have six
months where you know everything tells
me you're so busy and you're so and
you're working so hard to try and get
this show and this season and each
episode this season to be the best that
it can be that and then and then when
you finish you move on to your regular
life to the next thing so that's what we
have become I will say I think there's
an interesting there's a satisfying
conclusion to the season you know what I
mean I think there's a climax to the
season in the same where there wasn't
the first season I think so there is
that to look forward to I think so if it
is who knows that then this season would
be great
felt like starting a completely new job
with a completely new character you know
waking up in this kind of frenetic
fractious angry emotional lost you know
place and you know trying to piece
slowly piece your life back together and
kind of I approached it like honestly
like I was the hero of the story because
I think you know it's a much more
interesting way to approach you know
someone who people will consider a bad
guy in a villain to turn justify every
action that you take is kind of your
responsibility when you're playing the
character like that so
so I felt like I have a little bit of
free rein and what would this sort of
brain injuries and and everything I felt
like I had quite free rein to be
emotionally very volatile and so so that
was really exciting for me too to read
about oh you know in this scene he
throws a chair and I was like well what
if he doesn't throw a chair and he just
curls up in the corner and cries and
then in the scene where he's crying
because I'm in the corner cries what if
I smash something right you know just I
just just to keep it feeling really like
like on the edge all the time
[Music]